je suis joueur courrier arbitre
flamboyant dans la ligue nationale de
hockey pendant une dizaine d'années ron
fournier amorce sa deuxième carrière en
1987 d'abord à l'antenne de la défunte
cjms puis sept ans plus tard il passe
assez kaas est devenu en 2011 le 98 5 fm
carbo est appréciée au bota montréal est
heureux analystes coloré on l'a aussi vu
commenté des matches de la soirée du
hockey sur les ondes de radio-canada
olida de la zone du gardien
depuis 2018 toutefois des ennuis de
santé dont un cancer des ganglions
souvent gardé le communicateur de 71 ans
loin de son studio et mardi matin
il a annoncé la nouvelle de sa retraite
en direct à la radio qui l'employait il
ya une feuille à toute bonne chose via
outlook et l'italie vers house c'est sûr
que c'est plus facile
c'est pas facile mais je ne suis pas
triste du tout de prendre cette décision
là parce qu'elle ait été passée en tout
il aura un vrai pendant 33 ans derrière
un micro à échanger avec ses auditeurs
surtout des performances du canadien de
montréal
alors j'ai bu touzit lorsque ses
opinions tranchante son charisme et son
empathie en auront fait un favori du
public
c'est un gars qui était capable de
décimer les foules avec son cas toujours
parlé avec son cas je pense que c'est
une des choses que les gens vont retenir
de ron fournier fournier n'a pas exclu
d'éventuelles interventions dans les
médias mais pour les prochains mois il
préfère passer du temps avec ses proches
michel chabot radio canada montréal